MARTHA?
>> THEY REMAIN READY IT APPEARS.
LUCAS TOMLINSON.
LET'S BRING IN FOUR-STAR GENERAL
JACK KEANE, CHAIRMAN OF THE
INSTITUTE FOR THE STUDY OF WAR.
YOU'VE BEEN WATCHING THIS MINUTE
BY MINUTE.
THE NEWEST INFORMATION IS WHAT
JUST CAME FROM THE AMERICAN
PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT BIDEN THAT
OUTLINED THESE SANCTIONS AGAINST
RUSSIA.
HOW POWERFUL DO YOU THINK THEY
ARE?
HOW IS THIS PERCEIVED BY PUTIN,
DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, CERTAINLY PUTIN HAS
MADE THAT CALCULATION DEALING
WITH SANCTIONS.
WE'VE ADVERTISED FOR MONTHS WHAT
WE INTEND TO DO WITH SANCTIONS.
HE'S WAR-GAMED ALL OF THOSE
SANCTIONS.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL HAVE ANY
DETERRENT EFFECT ON WHAT HE'S
ATTEMPTING TO DO IN UKRAINE.
IF WE FELT THAT THESE SANCTIONS
WERE GOING TO HAVE SOME IMPACT,
I WOULD DIAL UP ALL OF THEM NOW.
THEN DIAL THEM BACK BASED ON HIM
DIALLING BACK HIS TROOPS.
HE'S GOT A DELIBERATE MULTIPHASE
CAMPAIGN PLAN THAT IS EXECUTED.
IT'S COMING INTO FOCUS NOW.
WE'RE GETTING A BETTER SENSE OF
IT.
IT'S DELIBERATE.
HE'S GOING BY PHASE.
PHASE 1 IS PUT TROOPS IN TO THE
TERRITORIES WHERE THE
SEPARATESTS ALREADY CONTROL.
HE DENIES THEY'RE THERE.
THEY'RE FROM THE 8th COMBINED
ARMS ARMY.
SECOND PHASE, HE'S LAID CLAIM TO
THE FULL REPUBLICS, TWO FULL
REPUBLICS.
2/3s OF THAT TERRITORY IS OWNED
BY UKRAINE MILITARY.
PHASE 2 WOULD LIKELY BE
INITIATED BY PREASSAULT FIRES,
AIR MISSILE, ROCKET, LONG RANGE
ARTILLERY AND GROUND MECHANIZED
ATTACK ACROSS THE LINE OF
CONTACT SIMULTANEOUSLY LIKELY IN
TO BOTH OF THOSE REPUBLICS WHERE
THE UKRAINE FORCES ARE EMPLOYED.
PHASE 3, PROBABLY A PAUSE AND
DOES HE GO IN TO THE REST OF THE
DONBAS REGION IN EASTERN UKRAINE
AND DOWN TOWARDS THE LAND BRIDGE
WITH CRIMEA.
THAT IS SPECULATION.
AND PHASE 4 IS WHAT WE'RE ALL
TALKING ABOUT, HE HAS MULTIPLE
OPTIONS HOW TO TOPPLE AND PUT
PRESSURE ON THE KIEV GOVERNMENT.
SO I THINK THESE PHASES ARE
GOING TO UNFOLD.
THEY ARE DELIBERATE.
SANCTIONS ARE GOING TO HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO IMPACT ON THE PLAN
THAT PUTIN IS EXECUTING.
>> Martha: WOULD ANYTHING HAVE
AN IMPACT?
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD THIS MOMENT
TO SPEAK MOMENTS AGO.
I WANT TO PLAY A LITTLE BIT OF
WHAT HE SAID AND ASK YOU WHAT
CAN BE DONE REALLY AT THIS
POINT.
WATCH.
>> WHO IN THE LORD'S NAME DOES
PUTIN THINK GIVES HIM A RIGHT TO
DECLARE NEW SO-CALLED COUNTRIES
ON TERRITORY THAT BELONGED TO
HIS NEIGHBORS?
THIS IS A FLAGRANT VIOLATION OF
INTERNATIONAL LAW.
IT DEMANDS A FIRM RESPONSE FROM
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
>> Martha: GENERAL, WE KNOW THAT
PUTIN DOESN'T SEE IT THAT WAY.
HE DETAILED IN GREAT EXHAUSTIVE
ESSAY ALL THE REASONS THAT HE
THINKS UKRAINE IS PART OF
RUSSIA.
HE BLAMED FORMER SOVIET LEADERS
FOR GIVING IT AWAY.
INTERESTING FROM A HISTORIC
PERSPECTIVE.
SO YOU HEAR PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAYING, YOU KNOW, IT WON'T STAND
ESSENTIALLY.
HOW DO YOU -- WHAT CHANGES THAT?
>> PUTIN REALLY HAS A VISION
HERE.
HE'S REVEALED THAT A COUPLE
TIMES.
ONCE IN THE PAPER HE WROTE LAST
JULY IN 2021, WHICH HE
CONTRIBUTED TO SIGNIFICANTLY,
5,000 WORDS.
AND THE NSE MEETING YESTERDAY.
WHEN I BOIL IT DOWN TO
SIMPLICITY, WHAT HE'S ABOUT,
HE'S TAKENING THE POST COLD WAR
BOUNDARIES AND RECONSTRUCTING
THEM.
HE ABSOLUTELY BELIEVES WHEN THE
SOVIET UNION COLLAPSED, THE
UNITED STATES LED AN EXPANSION
IN TO EASTERN EUROPE WITH NATO
AT THE EXPENSE OF RUSSIA AND
THEIR SECURITY.
HE WANTS A NEW SECURITY
ARRANGEMENT AND HE WANTS TO
ADDRESS THOSE BOUNDARIES.
THAT'S HIS VISION.
HE STARTS WITH UKRAINE AND THE
BELARUS.
ACQUIRING BOTH OF THOSE UNDER
HIS ORBIT IS FORMIDABLE.
ANYBODY THAT THINKS HE'S NOT
GOING TO PRESSURE NATO, IF HE
CARRIES OUT WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT IS MISGUIDED.
SO I ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS RIGHT IN
REINFORCING THE BALTICS.
I THINK WE SHOULD EVEN PUT MORE
TROOPS IN POLAND THAN WHAT WE'RE
DOING.
WE HAVE AN ARMORED BRIGADE
THERE.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE THE
PARATROOPERS THAT GENERAL
PETRAEUS AND I HAVE COMMANDED.
WE HAVE GREAT LOVE FOR THEM.
WE HAVE TO UPGUN OURSELVES IN
THESE NATO COUNTRIES.
THAT IS THE RIGHT MOVE.
I WOULD KEEP THE DOOR OPEN FOR
MILITARY AID FOR UKRAINE AND
KEEP THAT FLOWING.
MAKE CERTAIN THAT THERE'S STILL
THINGS THAT THEY DESPERATELY
NEED NOW.
LET'S STOP THE RESISTANCE THAT
WE'VE HAD FOR 1 1/2 YEARS AND
NOT GIVING THEM THE THINGS ON
THEIR SHOPPING LIST THAT WOULD
HELP THEM IMPOSE A COST ON
PUTIN.
SOME OF IT IS TOO LATE.
THEY DON'T HAVE TIME TO TRAIN
THEIR PEOPLE ON.
>> Martha: ROBERT O'BRIEN SAID
THAT HE SEES A SCENARIO THAT
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR ZELENSKY TO
HOLD ON TO POWER.
HE SAYS THAT WE NEED TO SUPPORT
AN INSURGENCY AND BASICALLY HELP
ORGANIZE I COLLECTIONS OUTSIDE
OF UKRAINE FOR REFUGEES AND
CONTINUE TO GIVE THEM SUPPORT.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
YOU THINK THAT IS FEASIBLE?
>> I AGREE WITH THAT.
PUTIN'S MILITARY IS AN OVERMATCH
FOR UKRAINE.
HE WILL DEFEAT THEM.
HE WILL NEVER DEFEAT THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
THEY WILL RESIST AND FIGHT TO
THE LAST RUSSIAN SOLDIER LEAVES
THEIR SOIL.
LISTEN, LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT
THIS.
PUTTING TOGETHER AN INSURGENCY
CAMPAIGN WITH MUNITIONS AND
WEAPONS, THAT TAKES TIME.
WE CAN ASSIST WITH THAT.
PUTIN CALCULATED THAT.
HE KNOWS HOW TOUGH THE
UKRAINIANS ARE.
HE KNOWS THAT BETTER THAN WE DO.
HE KNOWS THAT IS PROTRACTED AND
IT WILL HAVE A LONG-TERM IMPACT.
HE'S ACCEPTED IF HE CONDUCTS THE
FULL-OUT INVASION, THE COST OF
THAT AS HE HAS ACCENTED THE COST
OF WHAT HE BELIEVES IS A TOUGH
SANCTION REGIME.
THE SANCTIONS, THEY DIMINISH
THEM OVER TIME AND THE COUNTRY
GETS USED TO THEM OVER TIME.
THAT'S ANOTHER FACTOR.
THE SANCTIONS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IMPIMPOSING, I'M ALL IN FR
OF THEM.
I'M ALL IN FAVOR OF HURTING
PUTIN SIGNIFICANTLY AND TAKING
DOWN HIS CENTRAL BANKS AND
FOREIGN INVESTMENT.
ALSO I BELIEVE DEALING WITH THIS
INDUSTRY SECTORS AND CERTAINLY
THE PEOPLE INVOLVED.
I AGREE WITH ALL OF IT.
HE SHOULD PAY A PRICE.
I DON'T BELIEVE SANCTIONS ARE
NECESSARILY THE DETERRENCE THAT
PEOPLE THINK THEY ARE.
I THINK THEY SERVE A PURPOSE IN
DRAMATIZING THE SCALE OF THE
INTERNATIONAL VIOLATION THAT
PUTIN HAS COMMITTED HERE.
YOU GET OTHERS TO CONTRIBUTE IN
THAT SANCTION REGIME.
VERY IMPORTANTLY, IT'S ABOUT
PUNISHMENT AND RETRIBUTION FOR
THE SCALE OF THAT VIOLATION.
THOSE THINGS HAVE TO BE DONE.
IT'S A MORAL IMPERATIVE TO DO
THINGS LIKE THAT.
BUT DON'T KID OURSELVES TO THINK
THAT SOMEHOW THIS IS GOING TO
DETER PUTIN FROM THE OBJECTIVES
THAT HE FEELS THAT HE INTENDS TO
ACHIEVE HERE IN THE UKRAINE.
>> Martha: THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
SAID DIPLOMACY AND DETERRENCE
WERE TWO AVENUES.
RIGHT NOW DIPLOMACY HAS FAILED.
THE DETERRENCE WON'T BE USEFUL
IN TERMS OF STOPPING THE
ACTIVITY THAT THEY'RE
UNDERTAKING AND WHO KNOWS HOW
MUCH FURTHER THEY'RE GOING TO
GO.
>> ONE MORE POINT, MARTHA.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
THREATENED SERIOUS SANCTIONS
AFTER AN INVASION AND THEY USED
THAT BASIC PREMISE TO DETER THAT
INVASION.
WE NOW HAVE AN INVASION.
SO THAT'S STRATEGIC POLICY
IMPERATIVE HAS FAILED.
THAT'S JUST THE SIMPLY FACTS OF
IT.
>> Martha: WHICH YOU HAVE SAID
ALL ALONG ON THAT.
YOU BEEN A STRONG VOICE SAYING
NOTHING WOULD DETER THEM UNLESS
IT HAPPENED BEFORE THEY WENT IN.
OBVIOUSLY THEY HAVE DETERMINED
THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO BE THAT
PUNISHING AND IT'S WORTH THE
GAMBLE.
NOW THE SANCTIONS TEND TO
DIMINISH OVERTIME.
COUNTRIES GET WEAKER GETTING
TOUGH IN THERE AND WANT THE
TRADE.
WE'VE SEEN THAT OVER HISTORY AS
WELL.
THANKS, GENER